Everybody needs to buckle up because things
are about to get absolutely insane as Donald
Trump is set to nominate one of a few dystopian
Handmaid's Tale type ideologues, cultists,
literal cultists to the Supreme Court to replace
Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
Donald Trump has said he will be making the
announcement Saturday, five p.m. Eastern,
from the White House.
One of the people Donald Trump is reportedly
considering who is again.
Reports are that she is the frontrunner is
Judge Amy CONI Barrett, who is against Roe
v. Wade, against abortion, connected to the
right wing Federalist Society, part of a pseudo
religious cult, and has a long list of absolutely
disturbing beliefs, which we are going to
discuss now.
Why is Amy CONI Barrett a known entity?
She's a known entity because back in 2017
under Trump, she was confirmed to the 7th
Circuit Court of Appeals.
And so we learned a lot about her in 2017
to start with.
She is a strict constructionist who has criticized
Roe v. Wade many times and said that the court
is likely to chip away at abortion protections
on the Friday show.
I'll talk more about what that could actually
look like.
Barrett and her husband are members of a group
called People of Praise.
This is a cult.
I got e-mails from viewers whose families
were previously involved with people of praise.
It is a pseudo religious pseudo church cult.
It's not exactly a church.
It's a Christian para church organization.
And it is reminiscent of Gilli ad in Margaret
Atwood's Handmaid's Tale.
If you read about people of praise, you will
see that, for example, the highest office
a woman can hold in a people of praise.
Community is now called woman leader.
It used to be called Handmaid.
I'm not exaggerating that.
This is literally Trump going in the direct
direction of a Margaret Atwood's Gilliard.
I'm not making it up, as I mentioned.
Barrett used to be a member of the Federalist
Society.
That's the group that actually was bankrolling
the nomination of Brett Kavanaugh to the court.
Amy CONI Barrett is eager to get rid of Obamacare.
Barrett reportedly spoke to students will
know she did speak to students at Notre Dame
and reportedly said that a legal career is
merely a means to an end and that the end
wait for it is building the kingdom of God,
a religious cult.
This who believes legal careers are meant
to serve God is potentially going to be nominated
to the Supreme Court to replace Ruth.
Later, Ginsburg, that is what we are up against
here.
77000 votes in three states got us here today.
Now, buried is only a few of what are considered
to be the frontrunners.
So we could go into Barratt's court decisions,
which are disturbing, but she may not actually
be the nominee.
So we'll wait on that.
We'll wait and see who actually is selected
on Saturday.
The time will come for that.
So we are slowly but surely moving more and
more towards a status quo that resembles that
of dystopian fiction, including that described
by Margaret Atwood in Handmaid's Tale.
And the sequel, The Testament's, which I also
recommend.
I read it a couple months ago.
And this is where we are.
We have an election in under six weeks to
go from Ruth Bader Ginsburg to this lunacy
is beyond devastating.
Gilli ad is a sort of Republican religious
right winger wet dream.
And it is what Donald Trump is creating, a
sort of male dominated conservative society,
suppression of minority rights, prevalence
of certain people seen more as though they
are less than human and more like property
than others.
Not literal slavery, of course, at the suppression
of women's rights.
It's all happening.
Margaret Atwood created the story to serve
as a warning.
And the Republican Party under Donald Trump
is using it almost like a blueprint.
Republicans are trying to create that religious
body within government, within the Supreme
Court, giving them veto power over culture
and society.
It's not just this.
This is no longer like left versus right.
It's far deeper than that.
It's ideological.
It's dystopian.
It's a nightmare.
And we can't control everything.
As I said, but we can still control whether
we all get out and vote.
Forty five percent of eligible adults didn't
vote in 2016.
Nonvoters, one, so to speak, or if non-voting
was a candidate non-voting would have won
in something like 85 or 90 percent of the
states in 2016.
Let's not forget that we have agency here.
We can take action, but it looks like it's
going to get very, very ugly very, very quickly.
Let me know your thoughts about the direction
of all of this.
I'm
on Twitter at David Pakman,